chaque année pendant le temps des fêtes
une maison bien spéciale fait son
apparition sur le terrain du brésil
terre de pomme nico est rempli de petits
sacs contenant des biscuits en bénéfices
faits maison et d'autres friandises la
maison enfin des pistes danis fait le
bonheur des enfants qui font plusieurs
visites pendant le mois de décembre les
enfants viennent avec le pas lent et
elles ont de nouveau menacé sinon et
prenait tisseur qui s'amusent traîneau
episol et les cloches que je devais
dormir en est sûr est avait débuté cette
tradition avec son mari david sur est il
ya cinq ans ensemble ils ont construit
la maison de a à z os mamie j'allais
enfin je prends un peu de temps et les
points la population s'était donc
habitués à voir chaque année à paraître
cette décoration de noël unique lors du
décès soudain danis dans un accident de
voiture en ou 2018 la communauté s'est
demandé comment elle pourrait rendre
hommage à la dame
l'idée de reprendre la tradition est
venue naturellement aux bénévoles de la
west side improvements à aider les
enfants aiment en sabots beaucoup et
puis sa façon en appoint le laisser s'en
aller ça et dévie pour préfère lui tout
ça mis ensemble avec tout le monde
tout le monde les faits nous et
auparavant installé sur le terrain de la
maison des sourds est la décoration a
été déplacé devant le président pères de
l'église locale
chaque jour un bénévole se rend à la
maison pour la remplir de nouveau sac et
la popularité de cette attraction ne
cesse d'augmenter
l'an dernier plus de 400 sacs ont été
distribués et cette année les bénévoles
en ont préparé cinq cent des jeunes de
l'école de pornic ouest ont même mis la
main à la pâte pour aider le groupe
les 6e année nous avons aidé à porter
les sacs à préparer les sacs pour les
mettre on a eu neuf femmes qui sont mis
et coups du les sacs savent à peu près
par les deux mêmes et les enfants les à
vos papiers
la communauté compte poursuivre cette
tradition encore longtemps
cette année les curieux pourront
apercevoir la maison en pain élitiste
danis jusqu'au 7 janvier prochain
ici caf andré nadeau radio canada paul
nicot l'ouest